[Music]
so let's try a segue
into
the world of tony
and this may or may not make sense as a
segue but let's let's try it and then we
can go anywhere you want to go
the first time working with tony in
egypt
because this this is sort of the what
was the term you used
like a trap spider moment of sorts for
you
that definitely was okay so let's have
you describe what happened in egypt
so i got the call i was waiting for
which was
hey you know one of the shooters can't
go to egypt
i think he got sick or something and do
you have is your passport up to date can
you go like next week
and i was like you know absolutely
you know i'm there's no way i'm missing
that so
i
went to egypt i kind of jumped in you
know that that show had been going
already for a while and so they had ways
of doing things tried to do my best to
assimilate to the ways they were doing
things and bring what i could to the
table but
the thing that changed it all and like
tony
tony was tony was not like everyone that
came in the door it was like hey how's
it going you know he's
he plays it cool and and the other thing
is if he doesn't like you you are just
simply not going anywhere on that show
and there's a lot of people he didn't
like you know yeah he had pretty
particular i think if you were honest i
think if you weren't addicted to people
i think that if you carried yourself
in a respectable manner i think that if
you if you saw that you worked hard and
i think that if you saw that you could
like hang out and like
i have to admit there was a lot of
drinking on the show if you could hang
out and not become just like a sloppy
drunk
then you were kind of cool and you could
hang out but initially he wasn't going
to give you anything the thing that
changed it for me was with tony was we
were going out we were going to go out
and spend a night out in the western
desert with the bedouin
and
and we go we drive you know a few hours
outside of cairo we meet them in the
desert and you're like on a paved road
with just
sand on both sides
we meet this group of bedouin all in
their
like late 70s toyota land cruisers which
is the car of choice in the western
desert of egypt
and we're just going to go drive off
into the desert and i was like well okay
so we're driving across the desert i
should get up on the roof of one of
these cars and just film a bunch of car
to car stuff we're driving across the
desert how like how bad can it be
and so
five minutes later we're going like 80
miles an hour across the desert i am
absolutely terrified
of one hand on the camera and my other
arm my right arm was around a
four post bed that for some reason they
had strapped to the
roof of the car
and so i have my arm now by four post
bed this is like a bed with a huge
canopy above it is that what you mean
like one of those things yeah and it was
broken down into pieces
they had broken it down into the pieces
and strapped it to the roof of the car i
think that they thought that tony would
want to sleep in a fourth post bed like
out in the desert which is absurd
you know again like tony if you know
tony like all tony wants to do is go off
and like pass out in the sand you know
yeah anyways they had this ridiculous
thing on top of the car and it saved my
life because i was able to hold on to
the car i this whoever the driver was
must have been like i am going to show
this white boy you know and and so they
go barreling off across the desert and
and it is harrowing and i see tony
looking out the window at this
big ridiculous grin looking at me and
like oh yeah look at the new guys suffer
you know like this is this is great i
got great footage and also
what i think did it for me is by the
time we got to camp i had a
hematoma the size of like a
small nerf football on my bicep where i
was holding on
there was like deep purple where i'd
been holding that's how hard i was
holding on to this thing and that's the
kind of beating that it took up there
and i think that that act of he's like
oh this is a cat who's likes it i mean
i'm a physical shooter you know this is
a cat that's going to throw himself
completely into this and it's like a
light switch went off i landed in camp
he's like hey all right
that was a pretty rough ride i was like
oh yeah look at this i showed him the
bruise and
from that moment on tony liked me
i got called after that
like i said lydia was like this is a
benchmark moment he actually knows your
name after one show
do you want to come back you want to do
another i was like i'll do as many as i
can for as long as i can and that's what
i did so that was the introduction to
tony it just took a act of
i don't know i didn't have kids at the
time so i don't consider it too selfish
but i wouldn't i wouldn't recommend it
to any young shooters
you